avec sébastien chenu porte parole du
rassemblement national député du nord
candidat également à la mairie de denain
c'est notre invité politique ce soir
bonsoir sébastien chenu merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
commence avec l'actualité française
toujours dominé évidemment par la
mobilisation contre le projet de réforme
des retraites avec la prise de parole
aujourd'hui d'emmanuel macron quelle est
votre réaction le président qui comprend
les inquiétudes mais qui est prêt voilà
à discuter mais tout de même qu'ils ne
lâchent pas qui est déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout de cette réforme
je pense qu'il n'est pas dans l'adn des
venelles macron de se remettre en cause
et que tout ça ce sont des rideaux de
fumée
ce sont des artifices le président de la
république française a choisi de
déconstruire le modèle social des
français donc il peut communiquer il
peut mettre un âge pivot le retirer le
suspendre la réalité c'est qu'il
instaurera cette retraite à points
parce qu'il a décidé de l'intérêt de 2,2
delà de la bête remplacé parce qu'il a
décidé de servir des intérêts qu'ils
n'étaient pas ceux des français mais des
intérêts de grands groupes
il lobe ouvre la porte à la retraite par
capitalisation
on le voit bien à travers cette retraite
qui n'est aujourd'hui ce projet retraite
ni juste ni universel vous ne croyez pas
tout de même qu'il ya une part de
sincérité de la part du gouvernement qui
nous dit tout simplement que notre
système des retraites n'est pas viable
ainsi avec le nombre d'actifs avec la
démographie qui aura plus assez de gens
pour payer voilà les retraites des plus
âgés ça c'est quelque chose que vous
rejetez au rassemblement national on n'a
pas besoin vraiment de réforme
absolument nous nous avons considéré
mais pas seulement nous un certain
nombre d'économistes
y compris d'ailleurs l'ancien ministre
du budget de françois hollande qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui les capacités à
pérenniser
ce système des retraites capacité
financière le déficit du système de
retraites est tout à fait capable d'être
compensée par un certain nombre de
réserves de fonds de réserve qui existe
actuellement
et puis surtout une autre politique à
mener sur le sauvegarder notre système
de retraite dans le présent dans le
public il ne souhaite pas sauvegarder
notre système de retraite il souhaite le
déconstruire pour aller vers une
retraite à points à partir du moment où
on veut sauvegarder le système de
retraite
on va vers une politique du patriotisme
économique de la réindustrialisation du
pays
on va aussi vers une politique de la
natalité encourager le les français à
faire plus d'enfants pour que demain
évidemment il y ait plus d'actifs pour
payer les retraites de ceux qui partent
en retraite ces deux levier natalité et
patriotisme économique
emmanuel macron ne les utilise pas parce
que ce n'est pas son objectif que de
pérenniser notre système de retraite oui
bien sûr qui a la possibilité de
pérenniser ce système de retraite qu'on
soit bien clair quand vous nous dites on
peut aller chercher l'argent dans les
fonds de de réserves ça veut dire quoi
vous allez par exemple on parlait
beaucoup et de celle des avocats
auxquels 100 millions de raisons ça veut
dire qu'on sait non une première
compagne il faut aller piquer par
exemple dans ce genre de fonds de
retraite où on y lire il est aujourd'hui
deux types de financement possibles pour
compenser le déficit des retraites
vous avez l'unedic et la branche famille
qui vont redevenir excédentaire 3
milliards et 5 milliards de mémoire donc
là vous avez 8 milliards qui compense à
peu près le déficit déjà des retraites
et puis après vous avez un fonds
alimenté par le crds et par la csg qui
sont aujourd'hui qui est aujourd'hui
mobilisables qui est la révocation être
provisoire fonds rappellent qu'ils
avaient vocation à être provisoire on
est bien content finalement peut-être de
le trouver et qui à peu près d'une
trentaine de milliards d'euros
donc on voit bien qu'il n'ya pas la
nécessité aujourd'hui de crier au loup
le gouvernement a voulu affoler les
français et c'est une technique qu'on a
bien connu il affole les français
ensuite il agite la technique du pivot
ce qui permet à tous les syndicats de se
montrer hostile puis en fait après il
lâche sur le pivot les syndicats amis du
gouvernement est bien enclenché la
marche avec lui les autres passent pour
les méchants
le front syndical est brisé et le
gouvernement peut faire passer tout le
reste c'est à dire la retraite à points
en ayant levé le pivot alors marine le
pen 1 souhaite un référendum depuis le
début d'ailleurs elle l'a rappelé encore
une fois ce matin dans le même temps un
jordan bardella expliqué que votre parti
retirer cette réforme si le parti
c'est votre parti arrivé au pouvoir en
2000 22e on a du mal à comprendre
exactement quels seraient l'intitulé
tout simplement de ce référendum
mais vous savez un référendum on y
répond par oui ou non
donc il est temps que le gouvernement
couche sur le papier sa réforme des
retraites qui nous donne exactement le
texte qu'ils souhaitent soumettre au
franc soumettre aux français comme
d'ailleurs dans le passé jeudi
référendum de référendum sur maastricht
était pas un
c'était un texte qui était difficile
d'accès et pourtant les français se sont
passionnés et on a répondu oui ou non à
ce texte et bien c'est la même chose
nous demandons au gouvernement de mettre
sur le papier ce texte est les français
sauront répondre par oui ou non sur ce
texte sur cette réforme des retraites
et je pense que ça va plusieurs
objectifs d'abord ça permet aux français
de trancher
on est bien que le pays est bloqué et ça
permet de débloquer le pays parce que on
annonce qu'un référendum immédiatement
les grèves seraient levés les partisans
du pour les partisans du non on ferait
assauts de débats expliquerait leur
position expliquerait également comme je
le fais la capacité à sauvegarder le
régime des retraites
et puis les français trancheront le
gouvernement ne veut pas parce qu'il
sait qu'il va échouer sur un tel
référendum
il sait que les français sont hostiles à
son texte le gouvernement a peur des
français ils le sont hostiles dit
peut-être parce qu'ils n'ont pas compris
qu'il ya énormément de confusion il est
vrai que peu de français savent
exactement quelle sauce ils vont être
mangés avec cette réforme là n'est pas
là le le vrai coeur du problème de cette
réforme et par le fait de réformer en
lui même c'est qu'on ne sait tout
simplement parce que comment les choses
vont tourner pour pour nous chacun je
pense que les français ont très bien
compris que leur pension à les baisser
la retraite par points il suffit de
regarder ce qui se passe ailleurs en
suède 92% des retraites ont baissé ça
les français l'ont très bien compris
après le fait que le gouvernement ne
sont pas en capacité d'organiser des
projections financières de sap en
capacité de nous expliquer avec des
mécanismes
voilà des études d'impact ou combien les
français pourront toucher lorsqu'ils se
seront la retraite individuellement
selon leur cas là aussi des montres
l'impréparation total de ceux de ce
gouvernement sur ce sur cette réforme
des retraites je rappelle qu'elle est le
maquereau avec 1m dit lors du débat sur
la présidentielle qu'ils ne
reviendraient pas sur l'âge de départ à
la retraite
ll macron a menti aux français et il
continue alors il retire quand même
cette histoire des niveaux
écoutez c'est un subterfuge et je vous
ai expliqué que tout ça était cousu de
fil blanc
l'objectif de macron s'est passée la
retraite par points je note d'ailleurs
qu'ils ont retiré aussi un certain
nombre de critères sur la pénibilité la
pénibilité ça fait partie des axes très
importante cette réforme des retraites
par exemple des critères qui sont très
basiques porter des poids des choses
comme ça il ya beaucoup de gens qui
portent des poids dans leur métier des
aides soignants des manipulateurs en
radiologie des gens qui ceux qui
travaillent dans l'industrie dans les
supermarchés etc
ils ont retiré ce type de critères donc
on voit bien que cette retraite elle
n'est pas juste et puis l'on laissait
d'ailleurs se multiplier il nous avait
dit elle sera universel durera tout le
monde sera dans le même régime pas du
tout il ya aura plusieurs evil et on
peut le comprendre d'ailleurs moi
j'arrive à comprendre qu'il ya des
régimes particuliers parce qu'il ya des
situations particulières et parce que
tous les métiers ne se ressemblent pas
mais ces gouvernements étaient partis la
fleur au fusil en disant vous allez voir
ça va être plus juste ça va être
universel tout ça coûtera pas plus cher
on en est déjà à 10 à 15 milliards de
plus que les visites des retraites
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous soutenez
après 41 jours de grève c'est syndicats
les plus déterminés cgt unsa fo est ce
qu'il faut continuer à bloquer le pays
et notamment les parisiens qui souffre
effectivement je sais dire m moi je
comprends tout à fait la souffrance des
parisiens des habitants des grandes
villes des commerçants aussi également
qu'ils subissent tout ceci moi l'idée
n'est pas de soutenir des syndicats mon
boulot n'est pas de soutenir des
syndicats notre boulot activités du
rassemblement national
oui c'est de faire des propositions nous
en faisons des propositions sur le fond
et des provisions sur la forme pour
sortir des grèves d'ailleurs nous avions
proposé qu'il y ait une trêve
les syndicats n'ont pas souhaité un mais
celle ci était nous nous voulons le
retrait de ce texte parce que ce texte
il tape méchamment les français il va
leur faire mal à terme donc aujourd'hui
il ya des manifestations il y à des
blocages pas ce sont les seules façons
dans une démocratie de pouvoir se faire
entendre face à un pouvoir qui est tout
à fait sourd à ce que lui demande les
français retirer ce texte alors
mobilisation dans la rue également avec
parfois on l'a vu aussi lors des
manifestations de gilet jaune
des violences policières en tout cas des
violences aussi des manifestants en tout
cas selon les opinions bien souvent
aujourd'hui les proches de ce livreur un
cédric joue via mort à paris après son
interpellation par les policiers le 3
janvier a été reçu par christophe
castaner ils se sont déclarés
extrêmement déçu parce que les agents
n'ont pas été suspendues vous partager
leurs sentiments
mais comment ne pas partager le
sentiment de cette famille à laquelle on
pense qui a dû enterrer l'un des siens
je note d'ailleurs que la famille en
question a dit qu'elle n'en voulait pas
à l'ensemble de la police nationale
qu'elle en voulait à ce qu'ils avaient
et bien fait en sorte que leur leur fils
leur frère meurt mais qu'elle n'en
voulait pas la police nationale il y à
des actifs sont intolérables de dans la
police nationale on le voit d'ailleurs
les policiers même ne cherche pas à le
cacher il souhaite que la lumière soit
faite parce que c'est l'image de marque
également de la police de notre pays et
puis de l'autre côté vous avez la
paupérisation total cette police
il faut bien se pencher sur les causes
de tout cela vous avez une police qui
est à bout une police seconde à laisser
et qu'on laisse encore se faire taper
dessus dans certains quartiers je pense
également aux confié d'ailleurs qui sont
dans les mêmes situations
donc à partir du moment où on veut des
professionnels qui fasse respecter
l'ordre de façon républicaine ils le
font une très majoritairement il faut
aussi leur donner des moyens on peut pas
laisser notre police se paupériser comme
elle le fait et puis avoir ce genre de
fait divers régulièrement d'accidents et
et qui font qu'ils sensibilisent
évidemment tous les français mais la clé
de tout cela c'est avoir une police qui
soit doté de moyens qui n'est pas des
millions d'heures supplémentaires à
rattraper qui ne soit pas au bout du
rouleau
et puis évidemment faire en sorte que la
police puisse accomplir partout sa
mission car je note qu'il ya des
endroits où il est parfois plus facile
de donner un coup de matraque d'autres
effectivement il ya des quartiers dans
lesquels on va pas on ne va plus parce
qu'il n'a pas les moyens alors que sur
les gilets jaunes
évidemment c'est plutôt facile de taper
fort est-ce qu'on a clairement encore
peur de l'uniforme dans ce pays est ce
que la police ait respecté évidemment
bien à part ça n'avoir rien à voir ça
voilà la mort de cédric joue via mai
en même temps est ce que les policiers
aussi ne sont pas des victimes mais un
policier qui est mort à lyon cette
semaine
je pense que les français sont attachés
à leurs forces de l'ordre ils l'ont
démontré aux saillies et quelques années
avec charlie les français étaient tous
dans la rue pour dire qu'ils avaient
leur police les applaudir à ça
maintenant
oui le problème c'est à police est
devenue une cible pour certains alors ce
seront souvent les mêmes
les voyous les racailles d'extrême
gauche et les voyous les caïds de
quartier les dealers qui eux ne
respectent rien les black blocks
tous ces gens là qui sont nous avait dit
christophe castaner parfaitement
identifiés visiblement ils rentrent chez
eux tranquillement le soir après avoir
tabassé les flics et bien écoutez cette
situation n'est pas admissible où on
identifie les fauteurs de troubles et on
les sanctionne avec la rapidité et la
sévérité qu il se doit
ou alors on aura une police qui sera à
bout et on verra se multiplier des
accidents dans notre pays et tout le
monde que race et accidents les
municipales également qui approche à
grands pas vous êtes vous-même candidat
alors selon des informations de nos
confrères du figaro
niché au scrutin de mars de m e miz
julien de normandie prévoit de se rendre
dans des villes gouverné par votre parti
soit une tournée qu'on a qualifié de
antilles est reine il n'est pas candidat
lui même une réaction peut-être où il
veut monsieur de normandie qui est un
énarque qui va découvrir la vie réelle
en atterrissant dans les villes et les
villages de france devrait d'ailleurs
puisque et les ministres démissionner
immédiatement de son mandat de ministre
en fin de sa fonction ministérielle
puisqu'il est payé par les français
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il n'est pas
payé pour aller mener la guerre au
rassemblement national c'est la seule
chose qui d'ailleurs les obsède ils
feraient mieux d'aller trouver les
candidats pour marges plutôt que
d'essayer d'aller piquer chez les
socialistes ou chez les républicains des
candidats les déguiser les repeindre en
marcheurs parce qu'ils n'en n'ont pas et
même moi je trouve ça tout à fait
ridicule pour tout vous dire ces gens là
ne sont obsédés que par le rassemblement
national
ils sont passés dormandy l'époque cédé
par le chômage il n'est pas obsédé par
la paupérisation
moi je l'invite à venir à denain 38 % de
chômeurs 48% de pauvreté il a peut-être
un discours à nous tenir monsieur de
normandie
l'énarque de bercy plutôt que de dire il
faut pas voter pour le rassemblement
national parce que dans les villes du
rassemblement national
eh bien on va être de plus en plus pour
le rassemblement national parce que les
habitants sont heureux de la façon dont
leur ville et gérez vous dites ils
feraient mieux d'aller chercher des
candidats la république ans
alors il se trouve qu'effectivement amer
sur deux ne se représentera pas c'est
pas simple pour personne de trouver des
candidats notamment aux airelles vous
avez fait le plein vous vous avez trouvé
tous vos candidats ah bon on ne trouve
jamais tous les candidats qu'on aimerait
pouvoir trouver mais on a beaucoup de
listes sur tout le pays tous les chefs
de départements auront et liste du
rassemblement national de nombreuses
villes de plus de 10 mille habitants je
crois que devenir élu local
c'est difficile et qu'aujourd'hui on
voit bien quels que soient les partis
politiques il y a des difficultés à
trouver des candidats
la tâche est ingrate elle est mal
considéré elle est peu payés alors le
maire est centrale alors que libération
certainement l'un des personnages
politiques les plus absolus planifier
ainsi le préféré des français
c'est vrai et l'état central de
gouvernement laisse beaucoup de mères
seules face aux problèmes moi j'ai un
maire dans vos circonscriptions à main
qui a failli perdre la vie parce qu'il
se posait à des gens du voyage comme on
dit pudiquement c'est à dire à des
voyous finalement qui voulait simplement
s'installer sur des terrains sans
autorisation donc la fonction mère elle
est difficile on voit pas de soutien du
gouvernement
les dotations baisse régulièrement les
maires ne sont pas protégés ils sont mal
indemnisés ils sont le réceptacle de
toutes les deux bandes des français donc
c'est difficile parfois de trouver des
candidats
lens qui concerne le rassemblement
national nous nourrissons quelques beaux
espoirs les financements les finances on
en parle souvent du rassemblement
national est ce que ce n'est pas un
handicap dans la campagne de ces
municipales être un parti pauvres est
effectivement un handicap
nous nous sommes riches en électeurs et
pauvres financièrement mais il faut dire
que le gouvernement a décidé d'essayer
de nous faire plier par ce biais là
d'essayer en ou réclamant des millions
d'euros d'essayer de nous mettre à
genoux parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
nous battre dans les urnes mais nous ne
plierons pas nos idées d'ailleurs nous
dépasse ce n'est pas simplement des
structures politiques qui portent des
idées nos idées nous dépassent elles
sont ancrées dans le pays
nous sommes la première opposition à
chaque fois qu'on a demandé aux français
de voter depuis vanel macron ils nous
ont placés en tête
alors justement ces municipales qui ont
lieu dans un contexte particulier
france fracturé est-ce que selon vous ça
va être le là ça va donner le la de la
présidentielle
elles sont connues un pur pas forcément
être un vote sanction ces municipales
mais ce qu elle pourrait le devenir
justement cette année en 2020 oui vous
savez c'est le philosophe michel onfray
qui disait emmanuel macron c'est le
président de la fin de la france à
vienne et la fin de la france ait failli
m eh bien je crois que les municipales
sont l'occasion de dire que oui nous
voulons une france qui soit qui demeure
ce qu'elle est avec nos villages avec
l'identité de nos villes et puis oui
nous voulons une france qui soit
prospère et dynamique et reprendre le
contrôle de nos vies et modèles mâcon
c'est ce président du désordre absolu
qui n'aiment pas les villages de france
qui n'aiment pas les bourgades de france
vous avez ce châtiment quand même
manière complètement hors sol c'est un
président que ceux des balances et la
communication
c'est un président des métropoles c'est
l'homme des métropoles toutes ces
politiques sont en faveur des métropoles
moi qui suis un élu du nord
je vous le dis à lille vous avez accès à
tous à la santé à la culture aux
transports la l'éducation très
facilement venez à 40 km dans nos villes
comme denain etc et vous verrez si cet
accès il est aussi facile alors que ce
sont les mêmes français à qui on doit
les mêmes choses si ce n'est plus
davantage d'ailleurs si ce n'est plus
parfois
pour finir quels sont vos objectifs au
rassemblement national pour ces
élections alors pas d'objectifs chiffrés
parce que lier personne ne peut en avoir
très honnêtement parce que l' éclatement
total des forces politiques
aujourd'hui nous avait dit ne pas savoir
si on se retrouvera a2 a3 a4 second tour
nous évidemment c'est de voir nos mères
réélu
la douzaine de maires que nous avons
réélu et 2 x x ce nombre de maires et ce
nombre de conseillers municipaux
je crois que nous sommes bien partis
merci beaucoup sébastien chenu d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur arte france
porte parole du rassemblement national
et député du nord et vous l'avez dit
candidat à la mairie de denain dans le
nord